more than 25,000 teachers in Los Angeles
won't be going to work today after a
breakdown in contract talks the strike
in the nation's second largest school
district affects more than a thousand
schools and more than 600,000 students a
funding battle between teachers and the
district follows similar walkouts last
year in six states starting with west
virginia tony Tecopa was outside John
Marshall High School in Los Angeles Tony
good morning good morning when the bell
rings here and in fact all across Los
Angeles school will be open but it's
likely to be very different inside it'll
be run by an emergency staff of
administrators volunteers and
substitutes while teachers are out here
on the picket line it is their first
strike in 30 years and their argument is
quite simple if every public school kid
is to get a chance every public school
needs more funding we are more convinced
than ever that the district won't move
without a strike the Los Angeles
teachers union is trading chalkboards
for street signs today after more than a
year of failed negotiations with the LA
Unified School District I came to LA no
fight in the late 90s when there was
class size reduction and classes were 1
to 20 and now my classes are double it's
hard to breathe
hard to breathe in a class that size let
alone teach Yuriko Naqada hasn't
received a raise in more than 10 years
but she says what's really heartbreaking
is watching her students suffer we have
a nurse one day a week so if you don't
get sick on Wednesday you're out of luck
the Los Angeles public school population
is one of the most vulnerable in the
country 80% of students qualify as low
income and yet California's public
school funding per student lags behind
the national average and way behind
similar states like New York Los Angeles
Unified School District Superintendent
Austin Beutner
is there not a crisis here with
classrooms as large as 50 students
absolutely it's a crisis it's a state
crisis not a local crisis 90% of funding
comes at the state level while Buettner
has failed to reach a deal with teachers
he says he actually agrees with their
demands
so if money were no object
would you give the teachers what they're
asking for and more but more absolutely
if what you're saying is that you agreed
more funds need to be provided the
state's not giving them why aren't you
on the picket line I'm doing my work I
don't think closing our schools putting
our kids in jeopardy depriving them of
the learning that they need is the best
path to get more resource maybe that's
just where we disagree Buettner says the
teachers demands for a six point five
percent pay raise new caps on classroom
size and more funding for librarians
nurses and counselors
would actually bankrupt the district our
children aren't commodities they're kids
who need a good education parents Joanna
Belson and Jeannie turbo not only
support the teacher strike they plan to
keep their kids home in solidarity I
love her teachers and she loves her
teachers I can't have her walk past
those teachers and walk in the door that
school at this point there's no telling
when this might end the school district
has offered to meet most of the teachers
demands through the 2019 2020 school
year but no further meanwhile teachers
in Oakland California and the state of
Virginia have indicated that they may
strike next
bottom line John when the education of
thousands of kids is at stake people
don't want to hear and perhaps should
not have to hear there's not enough
money and that's absolutely right thank
you so much Sonny